foreign
[Music]
see I gotta tilt you
here again you're not smoking
and then you then you go like this
you have to tilt it
tilt
so
always tilt
[Music]
s
okay okay try it again
variant it's not gonna work okay you you
have to tilt him
stop
you're not trying to bend him backwards
when your elbow doesn't go out
help with us and go out
I will stay soon
he keeps going forward
[Music]
thank you
even even here that's enough you can
attack his face
here
I can't get I can't get in
if he's stopping me
he's saying I can't answer
right over here I'm not pushing on you
and then I can enter
[Music]
tilt
tilts
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
he should be falling before you throw
it
at your training slow
you don't want to take advantage of this
type of food
no light
right
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
and then try to be in the back
okay
remember the pattern okay he says I
don't know which techniques I'm doing I
will have to watch the video later right
uh when I'm always doing the coffee
the ton didn't feel that that's all
you're doing okay you always just feel
the pattern
the one thing you can do here
is uh you're doing a lot of these
versions right where you live here hmm
okay you can uh do a yield
it's right there
and that's your pattern okay
now I'm gonna make the pattern every
time
we kind of so it's nice
[Music]
and this one's probably not in the
packet
[Music]
you didn't send me a touch
I just keep feeling for that
okay this is a illusion of mine okay
because when he was doing uh
I wasn't really uh letting myself be
grabbed
I go I go right to the idea
sometimes with life with my hand because
sometimes his hand does it so I'm using
his hand now
I adhere to his hands
so when he comes in with whatever grab I
just reach for the same thing
but he tries to you're gonna do whatever
got it I'm not gonna go
I just re I just Reach Out And Touch it
we're stuck he's gonna have to do
something else
[Music]
I mean
I know it looks like he's
reaching for my hands
do you understand
well I go to reach for here
[Music]
soda
it is
again
music
[Music]
do you understand
don't panic
just make connection like you your sword
okay
so if you avoid his grab he's gonna get
your he's gonna grab you hey
you're trying to move his grabs out of
the way
you see that you got like a little Perry
going on there
hey so if I come here you're gonna grab
it
you got it
but I'm not gonna
you understand I'm not trying to clear
you
just reach
[Music]
thank you
guys excited okay
[Music]
this is different
this Ridge
stop
stuck
do you see
[Music]
try it again
thank you
foreign
[Music]
so much intention
whoa
[Music]
hey
this is the drill
is uh the Release Me Girl the whole
skill is the release food
the whole
theme
your cultivation
field
is meant to cultivate release
is what brings about
the reconciliation of the two minds
all your training for is training for
the skill of release
so
is not in
I throw him
it's when I feel
an attachment like here's tenchy not yet
do you see
and then I do tension now the drill is
wasted
but as I go and I feel eventually not
yet but I also feel him here you see so
this is where I chase and that and that
in that exact moment is the drill
not in whether he is thrown or not
it's when I feel myself
let's get stuck
oh I'm gonna go this way but he does
something else you see he brought his
hand around the other one and how
quickly can I change what I'm doing
that's the drill
so if I were to do the drill
I did the release in there about three
or four times
okay
and internal I don't need him to fall
don't need him to fall I just keep
releasing the attachment
does that make sense the fall is
coincidental
from the release if you wanted
okay
he was is not sparring okay